hello I am Jessica Chastain I am Sophie
Tana and this is the wired autocomplete
interview oh my god okay let's do it is
sophie turner English I am English born
and raised in Warwickshire England live
in New York it's sophie turner that's a
long line related to void your do I get
Boy George all the time and you know
what I met him and I met his brother and
they told me that I looked just like him
and I thought is that a compliment or a
compliment no it's definitely a
compliment he's beautiful man but no I'm
not it's sophie turner real ginger hmm
I'm not there's only one real joke
there's my material ginger here baby
actually when I dyed my hair I felt all
the consequences of being a ginger the
kicker ginger day we don't have that in
the United States you guys are terrible
to your eyes just England it's Sophie
Tana blonde yes as you can see it's
Sophie Tiana wearing a wig right now yes
I'm wearing a full wig American American
and Americans for the armpits to mark in
is a she's wig Theory going up it is
sophie turner related to tina turner
she is my mum that is the weirdest
question strange one I think it's your
voice oh yeah it's Jessica Chastain
amazing yes it's Jessica Chastain stupid
we would have seen Ron Howard's daughter
no I'm not
nope you do look like Bryce Dallas
Howard I do it's Jessica Chastain oh I
think it's supposed to say Emma Frost do
you know who I'm Afra stirrers nope
she's a mutant in the x-men world you
should know this it's Jessica Chastain
vegan ah I am 14 years it's Jessica
Chastain related to Julia Roberts that's
a compliment guy yeah what does that
come from maybe a beautiful smile thank
you
it's Jessica Chastain related to Brandi
Chastain is that she is a soccer player
who wrecked her shirt off when she
kicked the winning goal and was
Sports Bra love that love branding is
Jessica Chastain that drop Wow a lot of
x-men questions here is you lilandra
izzy is you know more oh yeah
does sophie turner have an accent not
for me but for Americans and other
people yes
you have an accent to me but you don't
have an accent to you do you know does
sophie turner have a sister
no I do not although I did have a twin
that died in my mum's stomach and a
sidekick told me that it was a girl so
technically just like feet I'm gonna
sing yeah this is related to Tina Turner
I've raised it to Tina non-adoption out
okay does Jessica Chastain have a sister
yes - does Jessica Chastain play the
piano I do not I'm just forced to play
Chopin because you know they know I like
to work like a workhorse do you play it
in crimson peak yes that is really me
playing the piano
wow that's firm and I don't play the
piano so ours in my trailer just Jessica
Chastain where glass is supposed to
she's a rebel mmm Jessica Chastain eat
chicken in the help no I don't I'm a
vegan she's a vegan guys we already
established this it's baked chicken it's
fricking pickin chicken its I eat
chicken Jessica Chastain speak
Italian certo
these cards are sticky they are all
Sofie Turner oh and Emilio Ark France no
we are not we do not associate with one
another I would rather her stay far far
away from me
no I'm kidding I love her and love
Emilia Oh Sophie Tana amazing William
still friends yes we are she is my best
best besties best arewe are sophie
Turner and Maisie Williams married
people do think that we're a couple
sometimes that's good that's beautiful
it's a beautiful friendship it's the
purest friendship I've ever had in my
life
Oh sophie Turner amazing amazing sisters
honorary sisters yes I see her as my
sister and she is my sister in Game of
Thrones she's your sister from another
mister and mother all right what is
Jessica - what it was just that what is
Jessica Chastain doing now what are you
doing playing a game that I don't really
understand
yeah what was Jessica Chastain's first
movie my first movie was Salome with Al
Pacino and he's the one who started my
career no biggie
um what is Jessica Chastain like she's
awesome
what is Jessica Chastain nationality I'm
American girl what what foundation does
Jessica Chastain use I don't wear
foundation because I think it's good to
let your freckles fly and your skin
breathe it really just I love this
what's safe what color is Sophie turn us
out all these hard questions it's blonde
what breed is Sophie Turner's dog my
first dog that I ever had was a northern
Inuit who played my dire wolf on Game of
Thrones how was your first dog it was my
first dog and then we had put a dance
and now I have two other dogs which are
Alaskan Klee pies and that is basically
a miniature husky so they look like baby
versions of my old dog what age is
sophie Turner I am 23 what height is
sophie Turner I am 5 foot 9 and 3/4 baby
don't get up
what tattoos does sophie Turner have oh
you got lots I got lots I've got a J
I've got a fire for Phoenix I have a
face on my leg I'm not Donald Trump's
face and you're like he's grabbing me on
to the next no tall how tall Jessica
Chastain Jessica Chastain 5 4 how to
pronounce Jessica Chastain I think it
depends on what country you live in my
favorite in France it's Jessica system
Wolfe sexy how Jessica Chastain is
changing the game Hollywood game
how are you changing the Hollywood game
by existing that's right baby how to get
Jessica Chastain red hair maybe you
gotta be born with it I keep only game
only 3 I must have been very popular
you are super popular you're right where
does sophie Turner live in New York but
I won't stay specifics where did sorry
Sophie Tana grew up Warwickshire in a
little village the population was a
hundred and all we had was a church in a
windmill that wasn't function where was
sophie Turner born it was
in a place called Northampton going
north after good place
it's Jessica's alright ready who is
Jessica Chastain married to I am married
to Shawn Luke capacity they proposal oh
but I just call him hey you who is
Jessica Chastain in Dark Phoenix what
didn't you like - no but I don't want to
get fired who does Jessica Chastain look
like I look like Jessica Chastain who is
Jessica Chastain related to finger
related to your mom and your dad's yeah
I learned that Jessica can speak Italian
I mean I can't really I lied a little
bit on that one what did you learn about
me some sad things actually yeah thank
you bye